[Musique]
par les enfants bonsoir vite bon les
chaises que tu es pressé nounours
j'apporte ce télégramme nicolas et
pimprenelle et savez vous pourquoi ils
seront contents de partir patron non
pourquoi pour faire le voyage sur notre
nuage
surtout pour ça et au pop up ou boum
boum alors on les prêts là dedans
aux parents ont envoyé un télégramme je
vous ramène chez vous il commence juste
à prendre vos nuits ans j'en étais sûr
je vous emmène sur notre nuage
smic à temps les gens tu viendras nous
voir je l'emmènerais aussi sur notre
nuage merci nous
[Musique]
mettez des vêtements chauds je vais vous
aider
juliette juliette je préfère que tu nous
es
[Musique]
supputations
les voyages forment la jeunesse
oh
je me rappelle il y a quelques années
cornichons net est un bébé ou vendions
de la laine le long des routes je mets
ma robe et méchant n'oublie pas ta qu'at
il fait froid et ceux petits cornichons
était couchée endormi il sévit nous un
panier sur de la laine il était tout
rose et potelets je vais mettre mon gros
fola automne dans la valise maintenant
n'oubliez pas l'hébreu center est une
grosse dame demanda de la laine rose
elle achète tout le panier et elles
l'emportent
et cornichons qui ne disait rien car il
dormait le chérubin
et moi tout à coup je me dis mais où un
petit coup de date butoir
heureusement que j'étais là au triple
galop se rattraper cette dame et j'ai
ramené d'autres petits cornichons dans
notre
beau pateras talent sang froid tu
viendras nous voir si pas sur votre
nuage
je n'apprécie pas beaucoup ce moyen de
locomotion l1 c'est nous qui viendront
me voir je préfère c'est rami a bientôt
en route plus enfants
cornichons couche toi vite d'accord nous
bouffe voyage ça lui va comme deschamps
enfin juliette à varna
on voyage les petits ou revoir
shirt ada un bientôt
chers amis
[Musique]
c'est gentil pour amener du marchand de
sable vous allez faire de la vitesse un
petit peu oui vous n'avez pas peur oh
non moi j'ai jamais peur alors en route
bonne nuit tous nos petits amis fêtes de
bourg heures
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]